another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
handing out instances of scp-437 as
weaponry to unsuspecting new researchers
dr bright has a real taste for mischief
bloodshed and root beer floats or as he
calls them the three major food groups
new researchers at the foundation with
their difficulty recognizing sarcasm
often find themselves in the crosshairs
of his goofier moods but one of his
cruelest jokes of all time however is
introducing new researchers to scp-437
without any kind of warning imagine
starting a new job and meeting someone
of a higher rank than you that you think
you can trust this person tells you to
check out a specialized weapon and when
you do you find trees that have
disturbingly human faces in their bark
sap made from blood and the muffled
sound of agonized screaming emanating
from within dr bright has been formally
censored for this behavior and warned
that if it continues he will be
responsible for covering all resulting
therapy bills